Це пісня про кохання угорською.
Так само гарно ці діти співають і українською.
Звичайна школа в угорськомовному селищі Велика Добронь на Закарпатті.
З українською у цих Учнів молодших
класів справи набагато краще, ніж у місцевих дорослих.
Зовсім поруч кордон з Угорщиною.
Дорослі або їздять туди на заробітки,
або займаються вирощуванням овочів, зокрема паприки.
Цьому заняттю навіть присвячений окремий пам’ятник.
Однак ми про це змогли дізнатися не одразу..
Бо питали українською.
Люди або соромляться, або відповідають угорською.
Краще розуміють питання російською.
Пам'ятник? Це пам'ятник..
Такий, де старі паприку в'язали?
Ми не вчили українську.
Більшість місцевих дорослих ходили ще в радянську школу,
де вивчали російську.
За підручники з української ці чоловіки навряд чи візьмуться,
враховуючи те, що у Великій Доброні більшість населення угорськомовне.
Прийняття нового мовного закону, відповідно до якого
приміром, у державних, комунальних закладах, у секторі послуг
мають спілкуватися українською, тут багато хто
сприймає як порушення інтересів національних меншин.
Я не знаю, що це буде. Буде то, що нас тут не буде.
Всі виїжджають за кордон.
Не знаю, хто придумав такий дурний закон. Нас не люблять.
У цьому селищі Сюрте, що розташоване всього
за сім кілометрів від Словаччини і за п'ятнадцять від Угорщини,
україномовних родин – приблизно 20 відсотків.
А загалом середовище тут - мульті-культі.
Мовний закон не вважають чимось страшним.
Я знаю, що живу в Україні. Намагаюся вивчити українську.
Хочу говорити українською, угорською, російською так само.
Чим більше людина знає мов, тим більша в неї культура.
Одинадцятикласник Мартін - етнічний угорець.
Ще рік тому він боявся, що не складе ЗНО з української.
Але останні півроку інтенсивно зайнявся вивченням державної мови
разом з учителькою-репетиторкою.
Щоденно присвячує заняттям мінімум дві години.
Особливо він захопився українською на весняних канікулах,
коли для дітей з угорськомовних шкіл Ужгородського району
провели україномовний табір. Українську вивчали
за ось цим експериментальним підручником - "Українська: лайфхаки".
Найкращий підручник, каже Мартін, який він бачив за все шкільне життя.
Мені в цій книжці подобається, що автор написав все,
щоб було легко зрозуміти навіть угорськомовним.
Мовний табір для школярів старших класів
шкіл національних меншин Закарпаття і Чернівецької області -
спільний проект Міносвіти і громадської організації "Гоу Глобал".
Назва проекту "Бомбезно".
Одне з гасел: "Прокачай скіли!"
Мета - щоб діти нацменшин не боялися ЗНО.
Бо страх, кажуть вчительки української, самі угорки за національністю,
у дітей великий. Адже знати добре українську в середовищі,
де говорять лише угорською, досить важко.
вчительки вважають, що методика викладання української в школах нацменшин
і вимоги до учнів потребують серйозних змін.
Мовляв, від угорськомовних дітей не можна очікувати
такого ж рівня знань української,
як від дітей з україномовних родин.
Учні перших класів в україномовних школах  вчать
вже знаючи мову, вчаться читати і писати.
угорськомовних школах проходять лише усний курс.
І лише в другому класі починають вчити літери, писати і читати.
У 3-4-му дорівняються до учнів з україномовних шкіл.
Діти, вважає Світлана, просто не встигають засвоювати програму.
До того ж, не в усіх школах Закарпаття є достатньо вчителів з української.
Ось у цій школі в селі Велика Добронь хоч нині взяти б на роботу двох філологів.
В ідеалі вони мали б знати обидві мови.
Наталія Пазюк, сама родом з Ужгорода,
три роки тому приїхала у селище Малі Геївці викладати українську,
тепер сама вивчає угорську.
Третій рік працюю, на практиці бачу, що діти хочуть знати,
діти володіють, хто як, але стараються.
Одинадцятикласниця Христина хоче стати філологом.
Вона також брала участь у проекті "Бомбезно".
Це додало їй упевненості, вона стала краще говорити українською.
Дівчина хотіла б, аби в школах нацменшин
було впроваджено таке ж цікаве і креативне викладання української,
щоб угорськомовне населення не відчувало примусу.
Принаймні так вона сприймає новий мовний закон.
Українську мову тим, хто живе в Україні, всім треба знати.
Але і національну не треба забувати.
Це, додає директор школи у Великій Доброні Йосип Кантор,
гарантовано Конституцією України.
Наразі він очікує висновків Венеціанської комісії щодо нового мовного закону.
Йосип Кантор погоджується, що української в школах нацменшин недостатньо.
В середньому 4 години на тиждень.
Та й добрих навчальних матеріалів з української раніше не було.
Досі немає і вкрай необхідних усім учням
угорсько-українських словників, які були б затверджені міністерством освіти.
Тож, каже директор, не дивно, що угорськомовні випускники
не дуже добре здають ЗНО.
У 2018 році 54 відсотки наших випускників,
на жаль, не подолали поріг здав/не здав, що дійсно забагато.
Але, з іншого боку,  та сума - середньостатистична цифра
по Закарпатській області була понад 70 відсотків.
Так що це трохи краще ніж у середньому, але все одне забагато.
Пристрасті навколо закону про держмову занадто політизовані,
вважає вчителька української, угорка за національністю Катерина Голош.
На її переконання, в такій атмосфері діти навряд чи зможуть полюбити українську.
Я як вчитель ще більше буду старатися, щоб у учнів
не виникало таке несприйняття до української культури,
до вивчення мови, або небажання, або страх.
Катерина допомагає Мартіну у підготовці до ЗНО.
Якщо він здасть іспит добре, то зможе вступити на перекладача
з англійської в український ВИШ.
Якщо ні - то поїде вчитися в Угорщину,
як це вже давно роблять багато випускників шкіл на Закарпатті.
Мартін радіє, що цього року Міносвіти знизило поріг ЗНО
з української для випускників шкіл нацменшин.
Він сподівається, що з приходом нового президента
в Україні закон про держмову реалізовуватимуть
з більшим урахуванням прав нацменшин.